j'ouvre notre second débat tout de suite
dans ce sens public débat de société sur
un pilier de nos démocraties la liberté
de la presse pilier fragilisée par la
désinformation à grande échelle les
régimes autoritaires on y revient le
complotisme grandissant qui sont ces
nouveaux ennemis de l'information avant
de répondre à ces questions premier
constat le manque de confiance des
Français dans leur média Flora sauvage
c'est une majorité de Français suivent
l'actualité avec intérêt la perte de
confiance envers les médias est une
tendance de fond plus de la moitié
d'entre eux pensent qu'il faut se méfier
de ce que disent les médias sur les
sujets d'actualité et 59% des Français
estiment que les journalistes ne sont
pas indépendants face aux pression du
pouvoir et de l'argent ce qui est assez
inquiétant c'est cette suspicion qui
semble poindre à l'attention ou en
direction des des journalistes et des
médias en particulier une suspicion qui
est nourrie par de nombreuses
communautés en ligne qui soient
idéologiquement teintées ou des
communautés complotistes qui vont
diffuser en ligne des
narratifs visant à faire croire que les
médias sont pilotés par le système à la
méfiance à l'égard des médias s'ajoute
la fatigue informationnelle si l'image
des journalistes se dégrade c'est aussi
lié à la concentration des médias selon
ce sénateur il est temps d'encadrer
cette concentration des médias tout en
respect la liberté d'expression en
faisant son job chacun son métier j'ai
envie de vous dire à la fois les
questions de journée c'est les
politiques moi je ne juge pas forcément
du travail des journalistes mais je dis
que parfois il y a des orientations
éditoriales qui sont pas du tout en lien
avec l'actualité réelle et le vécu des
gens qui ont plutôt une envie surtout de
faire amplifier des thématiques se
creuse entre les médias et les Français
la télévision reste la première source
d'information devant Internet la presse
écrite et la radio un quart des 18 24
ans affirme toutefois s'informer grâce
aux réseaux sociaux comment renforcer la
confiance dans les médias qui sont les
nouveaux ennemis de l'information à la
petite qu'on a choisi pour ce débat là
je vous propose d'accueillir nos invités
Laurence zenerveau bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directrice du cercle
de réflexion destin commun et co-auteur
d'un rapport intitulé informations 50
nuances de défiance on va en explorer
quelques-unes Christophe Deloire bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes secrétaire général
de Reporters sans frontières et je
signale la sortie aujourd'hui
de se recueil la mère vue par les plus
grands photographes sans photo pour la
liberté de la presse voilà vous pouvez
participer vous aussi à aider Reporters
sans frontières et les journalistes qui
sont un peu partout sur le terrain
Jean-Bernard Schmidt bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directeur de l'École
de Journalisme W directeur délégué du
Centre de Formation des Journalistes et
qu'au fondateurs directeur général de
spicy et co-auteur on va citer votre
livre avec Thomas Huchon du livre anti
fake news qui est publié chez First
édition Laetitia cruppa et guitariste
politique est évidemment resté à mes
côtés allez on démarre sur en
rebondissant après le sujet sur la
défiance des Français pour pour les
médias pour la presse Laurence de
nerveau elle est stable elle est
grandissante qu'est-ce qu'on peut en
dire alors l'idée que nous avons eu en
produisant cette étude qui s'appelle 50
nuances de défiance c'était d'abord que
lorsqu'on parle de désinformation il
faut commencer par beaucoup mieux
comprendre le rapport des Français à
l'information et en l'occurrence ce
rapport et on va le voir pathologique et
ce titre 50 nuances de défiance veut
surtout insister sur le fait que on a
trop souvent un cadrage binaire sur ce
sujet il y aurait les rationnels d'un
côté les complotistes de l'autre on va
voir que c'est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça et que ce cadrage binaire est
dangereux parce qu'il renforce la
défiance de ceux qui déjà seraient
tentés par certaines orientations
certaines lectures complotistes je pense
qu'effectivement cette défiance dans les
médias qui est assez généralisée
progresse effectivement aujourd'hui
selon nos chiffres c'est seulement un
Français sur 10 qui dit qu'il n'a pas de
difficulté à faire confiance aux
journalistes mais ce qui est surtout
préoccupant c'est cette notion de
pathologie qu'on peut rapprocher de
l'univers de l'alimentation on parle
parfois d'infobésité c'est ce rapport en
fait entre l'anorexie et la boulimie ou
à la fois on surconsomme de
l'information et en même temps on est
dans l'overdose voilà et ça ça génère
des réactions très parfois douloureuses
des risques de dépression des gens qui
nous disent j'en ai trop eu pour mon
petit cerveau et j'en ai pleuré et puis
aussi un égarement on n'arrive plus à
démêler le vrai du faux voilà
effectivement on va proposer et détaillé
encore un peu plus tout ça Christophe
Deloire c'est pas seulement une maladie
française la défiance vis-à-vis des
médias la défiance est une maladie
française au delà des médias quand on
regarde vous savez le fameux test du
billet de banque ou du portefeuille
perdu et qu'on vous demande est-ce que
vous pensez que votre voisin va la
ramener est-ce que vous avez confiance
dans la personne qui passe dans la rue
pour aller le restituer les taux en
France sont désastreux il y a cela des
experts des explications historiques
notamment liées
au régime de Vichy à une forme de perte
de la fierté nationale enfin il y a eu
des livres très savants qui ont été
écrits sur le sujet donc quand on pense
que quand on analyse la question de la
défiance des médias il faut constituer
en général qui est la question de la
défiance en France donc ça qui est plus
grande
les phénomènes de polarisation de de
d'attitude parfois très hostile aux
médias et notamment aux médias du camp
d'en face supposé qu'en en face et je
rejoins tout à fait ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure à propos du qu'il faut
absolument éviter
une espèce de découpage de la population
en disant il y a d'un côté les gens de
raisonnable de l'autre ce qui serait
complotiste c'est si on veut venir à
bout des incompréhensions c'est clair
qu'il faut pas commencer par
évacuer une partie de la population
si on regarde les sondages qui sont
publiés chaque année dans la croix et en
essayant de dépasser le biais de
négativité qu'on a tous et que les
journalistes suivants
de la défiance l'un des grands éléments
de la fatigue informationnelle
le côté que vous voulez vous voyez tout
en noir ce biais là il est il est
beaucoup dénoncé donc si on essaye de
s'en détacher si on regarde des sondages
de la croix il y a pas de décrochage sur
les valeurs c'est à dire les Français
croient aux valeurs du journalisme quand
les journalistes sont critiqués c'est au
nom des valeurs du journal
il y a une revendication sur
l'indépendance éditoriale sur
l'intégrité de informations sur le
pluralisme et nous on avait lancé dans
les 15 derniers jours de la campagne
électorale un bus pour le droit à
l'information on a organisé des
assemblées citoyennes il y a trois
revendications
un là on est perdu devant ce flot ça
envoie la fatigue informelle et on a
besoin de se repérer deux on a besoin
d'éléments sur la transparence des
médias et l'intégrité de l'information 3
on veut pas simplement que vous me
disiez des vérités factuelles on veut
que vous parliez de l'ensemble de la
réalité donc il y a une aspiration un
pluralisme alors on y reviendra en
détail parce qu'effectivement ça rejoint
pas évidemment que certains des thèmes
qu'on a prévu d'aborder dans dans ce
débat Jean Bernard Smith vous former
maintenant de les futurs journalistes en
préparé c'est quand même un métier moins
recherché qui a 30 ans quand on a
démarré est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est vrai ou pas et ben justement c'est
très intéressant on en parlait
précédemment
on est dans une phase de fin de concours
dans les écoles de journalistes là c'est
la semaine prochaine les résultats donc
là on a vu défiler énormément de
candidats et de candidats mais pourtant
le métier journaliste quand on fait des
sondages il est en bas de la pile c'est
vraiment
politique enfin politique qui qui m'a
l'air corps des journalistes néanmoins
c'est une profession qui fait encore
rêver les jeunes c'est ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle ça fait encore rêver les jeunes
et pas pas parce qu'il s'agit d'aller
voyager certains reporters et tout ça
nous là je sors de un mois de Doro de de
sélection de candidats de candidates je
peux vous dire que ce qu'il met en avant
c'est l'envie de transmettre une
information vérifier claire l'envie
d'éclairer le monde l'envie d'être
honnête l'envie de de vraiment
d'expliquer le monde y compris de façon
très locale d'ailleurs ce sont des
jeunes qui sont très conscients des des
changements que les changements
climatiques vont impliquer sur sur notre
profession et donc en fait on peut se
réjouir de ça quand même et c'est assez
paradoxal parce que quand on voit le
climat de défiance phénoménale
effectivement envers la presse et bien
non il y a des jeunes qui sont vraiment
encore stimulés vraiment encore motivés
pour ça et alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'ils sont motivés par
l'idée on pourra peut-être en parler en
parler de différence de journalistes il
y a des mots qui reviennent en
permanence l'idée d'un journaliste de
solutions donc agent qui amène justement
qui laisse pas le public au milieu du
gué ça c'est une grande pas toujours
négative on propose son négatif d'accord
alors attention il faut pas être
caricatural non plus c'est pas
simplement dire les trains qui arrivent
à l'heure et que les belles histoires
mais c'est pas laisser le public au
milieu du gué en soi il y a un problème
et on vous laisse comme ça il y a des
solutions certaines vont être bonnes
d'autres vont être mauvaises mais on
vous les explique ça c'est hyper
important et une autre chose qui ressort
énormément de ce qu'on peut entendre
chez les jeunes l'envie de faire du
décryptage du fact checking parce que ça
contribue à l'idée de il y a 30 ans
exactement
rapprocher les gens de l'information
mais c'est vrai que c'est différent on
n'est plus dangereux voyager à travers
le monde c'est plus le le mythe du Grand
sur le terrain mais c'est plus le même
terrain allez avec peut-être on peut
évoquer leurs énervant il faut qu'on
balaye nous devant notre porte aussi
voilà on est des journalistes ici qui
des bâtons sur sur la liberté de la
presse et sur la défiance envers les les
médias dans les critiques principales
celles qui revient le plus souvent c'est
quoi c'est la partialité quand vous
dites il y a une sorte de de rapport un
peu pathologique au travail des
journalistes chez les Français c'est ce
qui est reprochait en premier ou pas
d'ailleurs j'ai pas la réponse
effectivement c'est la négativité le
côté anxiogène et extrêmement négatif de
l'info du coup c'est plus d'un Français
sur quatre 28% qui disent je regarde
moins les informations parce qu'elles
sont trop négatives et ça monte jusqu'à
35% chez les femmes c'est intéressant de
le souligner une femme sur trois quand
même qui dit ça donc cette négativité
aussi une forme de partialité mais ça je
pense que justement à un moment il va
falloir l'assumer parce que la
neutralité parfaite est-ce que les
médias disent bah voilà moi je suis un
média de droite je suis un média de
gauche ou est-ce que comme nous on
essaie de le faire ici on essaye de
garder une forme de de neutralité ou en
tout cas de pas afficher les opinions
j'essaye de le faire je sais pas s'il
était les spectateurs ils sont censés je
pense qu'en tout cas il faut que les
journalistes assument le fait d'être des
personnes humaines qui en tant que
telles ont une subjectivité mais oui
mais ça m'arrive moi pardon c'est très
égotique ce que je fais mais ça m'arrive
dans un débat de dire ce que je pense
évidemment de temps en temps mais voilà
je je porte pas mes opinions en étant
d'arriver c'est qu'en fait nous ce qu'on
a identifié c'est une grande illusion
dans le rapport à la fois plusieurs
illusions d'air première illusion on a
fait beaucoup de qualité on a écouté les
gens dans des focus group pour aller un
peu au-delà des chiffres des sondages on
a énormément entendu l'expression je
coupe je ne regarde plus etc première
illusion parce qu'en fait cette même
personne une minute après disait bon je
regarde encore une heure par jour les
chaînes d'info continue donc cette cette
inconscience de la dépendance et de
l'addiction deuxième illusion c'est
quasiment le même mot je recoupe et
cette personne en fait pareil dans la
conversation recoupait entre des médias
de ligne éditoriale exactement analogue
donc voilà un illusion de d'esprit
critique de rapport critique à l'info et
surtout cette notion de choix je choisis
mon information je vais quasiment être
dans ce qu'on a appelé une customisation
du réel parce que l'information est trop
négative trop etc sauf que là-dedans
aussi il y a une illusion monumentale
c'est en fait un rejet du de
l'éditorialisation qui est évidemment le
rôle des journalistes et qui est leur
valeur ajoutée leur valeur première sauf
que cette éditorialisation sur les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui évidemment
qu'elle existe sauf qu'elle est dans un
modèle opaque opéré par des algorithmes
alors je voudrais qu'on revienne sur le
classement que vous publiez chez
reporters Sans Frontières correspondent
de la liberté de la presse la France
était la 24e place du classement mondial
alors il y a des pays qui sont devant
nous comme la Lituanie le Portugal le
Timor oriental Lettonie ou encore la
Namibie bref bon je vais pas tous les
citer on remonte de deux places quand
même bon comment expliquer ce classement
qu'est-ce qui justifie le fait qu'on
soit qu'on soit pas dans les je sais pas
les cinq premiers ou les 10 premiers
vous voyez le biais de négativité il y
en a beaucoup plus derrière
une interprétation radicalement
différente alors je suis pas en train de
dire que la situation est parfaite en
France loin de là
ils sont à la 45e place et il y a des
grandes démocraties qui sont derrière et
et il y a un pays de 25e sur 180 pays et
les pays du nord de l'Europe
du Nord sont dans les premiers une
culture démocratique plus grande non ce
qui est spécifique en France et
d'ailleurs ce sur quoi il y a dans les
sondages une très grande demande
populaire c'est d'avoir la question de
l'indépendance éditoriale
il y a un modèle français qui est né
d'ailleurs d'une forme de faiblesse
historique des médias mais qui a
peut-être entretenu cette faiblesse
c'est que les grands groupes de médias
appartiennent à des groupes industriels
qui ont des intérêts dans d'autres
secteurs c'est pas d'abord des groupes
de médias même en Allemagne et parfois
dans des pays d'Europe du Nord ou la
concentration est plus grande dans
l'absolu c'est à dire des plus grands
groupes en termes de parts de marché
mais l'objectif premier du groupe c'est
de produire des contenus
et ça ça crée une suspicion une
suspicion qui ne repose pas que sur des
illusions
de la part des de des français avec plus
de de trafic d’influence d'une certaine
manière de conflit d'intérêt en tout cas
qu'ailleurs
il y a une animosité grande contre les
journalistes qu'on peut relever dans des
meetings politiques dans des discours
politiques qu'on peut retrouver dans la
rue évidemment alors sur les réseaux
sociaux et ça malheureusement sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est à peu près partout
que les journalistes qui prennent il y a
pas que les journées qui prennent ça
c'est de libération de la parole
indicatif
et l'une des raisons de la légère
remontée c'est que il y a eu moins de
manifestations moins de violences dans
les manifestations à la fois de la part
des policiers d'une année sur l'autre du
fait de l'adoption d'un nouveau schéma
national de maintien de l'ordre qui
avait apporté des améliorations dans les
mêmes si ces dernières semaines dans les
premières manifestations
de violences comme dans les
manifestations d'idées gilets jaunes
assez grande avec des seigneurs de
lynchage dont on se souvient alors vous
vous l'avez évoqué la question de la
concentration des médias en fait entre
les mains de de groupe ou de quelques
milliardaires
écoutez ce que dit sur ce thème oui
nettoyeur qui est député
insoumis à les filles de Val-de-Marne
pourtant aujourd'hui les Français
expriment une grande défiance vis-à-vis
des médias cette défiance repose
justement sur le risque de conflit
d'intérêt de censure voire
d'auto-censure des journalistes quand on
sait que 90% des médias sont possédés
par 8 milliardaires il est donc
essentiel que les médias conservent leur
indépendance par rapport à ces
milliardaires c'est pourquoi le 24
novembre nous défendrons notre
proposition de loi visant à mettre fin à
la concentration dans les médias
Louis Boyard qui comme d'autres
personnalités de la France insoumise
sont régulièrement invités sur les
chaînes du groupe Bolloré un des
milliardaires qu'ils attaquent
aujourd'hui bon bref on peut passer
voilà on peut passer sur l'incohérence
mais bon c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
un sujet Louis Goya mais sur la
conscience pardon il faut le dire quand
même c'est aussi le rôle du service
public de dire ce genre de choses et
alors je voudrais revenir sur la
concentration des des médias ou même
quelques milliards est-ce que c'est
l'une des 50 nuances la défiance dont
vous parlez dans votre rapport est-ce
que ça revient ça ou est-ce que c'est un
peu sous les radars de l'hôpital
et c'est ça qui est intéressant
justement et parce que il y a aussi une
grande confusion sur les sources dans
dans le rapport des Français à la
formation
en fait une confusion entre la notion de
canal et la notion de source par exemple
une personne à qui on demandait alors
vous où est-ce que vous allez chercher
de l'information elle nous répond sur
internet je sais c'est pas bien c'est
pas le problème d'aller sur internet
c'est où est-ce qu'on va regarder
qu'est-ce qu'on va lire sur internet
mais on sait que sur enfin en ligne en
fait on a une mémoire des sources qui
est bien bien moindre que sur la
presse-papier ou même ou même télévision
radio voilà donc ça c'est un sujet genre
avis là-dessus parce que on pourrait
dire ça dépend du milliardaire ça dépend
de de ce qui est mis en place au sein
des rédactions toutes les rédactions qui
sont des médias qui sont possédés par
ces par ces groupes voilà ils sont pas
tous interventionnistes enfin il faut il
faut donner de la subtilité un peu à
cette voilà c'est pour ça qu'il y a une
limite à la parole politique sur cette
question là parce que évidemment quand
on travaille dans les médias on sait que
les choses ne sont pas si simple je veux
dire j'ai fait toute une partie de ma
carrière dans le service public si on
croit qu'on a pas des pressions dans le
service public on se trompe j'ai fait
toute une partie de ma carrière dans le
privé on a d'autres types de pression
c'est ce sont d'autres intérêts avec
dans les deux cas d'ailleurs une grande
liberté de travail certains sujets sont
peuvent coincés donc ça il y a moi je
prends sauf certaines chaînes c'est
notamment du groupe Bolloré qui sont
plus identifiés honnêtement je pense que
on peut faire extrêmement bien son
métier et la notion d'indépendance et
justement finalement assez relative par
rapport à aux propriétaires des médias
on peut faire extrêmement bien son
métier de façon extrêmement libre au
Figaro au monde etc mais alors là-bas je
suis d'accord avec vous n'est pas
nécessairement pardon jamais et le côté
indépendant justement quand j'ai lancé
mon média on disait oui vous lancez un
média indépendant indépendant tout le
monde avec ça à la bouche bon quand vous
avez lancé spicy dans les gens ils se
passent pardonnez-moi ici bon dans les
faits moi je considère aujourd'hui qu'un
journaliste au Monde qui pourtant
appartient en grande partie en tout cas
ils sont plusieurs Matthieu pigas et
Xavier Niel est indépendant et
d'ailleurs ça veut pas dire que ils
peuvent pas il peut pas y avoir des
conflits etc mais ce sont des
journalistes indépendants je ne pense
pas qu'il y ait une crise d'indépendance
sur le traitement des sujets dans des
rédactions comme le monde etc ou
L'Express donc en fait je pense que
cette question est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant que que finalement ça soit
assez peu relevé par la population parce
que par le public parce que je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres notions qui
instaure cette confusion dont vous
parlez et cette et cette défiance par
exemple moi je pense que l'un des
principaux problèmes et ça c'est à la
décharge du public
le monde de la formation est un tel
bazar vraiment je un tel bazar avant
c'était quand même globalement simple
l'information elle est arrivée par des
canaux qui étaient hyper identifiés de
la presse d'ailleurs plus ou moins
marquée service public plutôt droit
plutôt gauche afin globalement c'était
c'était simple aujourd'hui c'est plus du
tout simple ça arrive de partout vous
avez une multitude d'émetteurs en
permanence elle est en temps réel elle
est ça faut pas l'oublier comptable
amendable partageable en permanence fait
que les repères sont tous brouillés et
elle a décharge du public c'est un bazar
et c'est un far west ce qu'on appelle
l'infobésité quoi c'est là que c'est
l'infoidité il y a une idée de
perception de plus en pouvoir etc aussi
là il y a un côté simplement c'est un
univers totalement débridé et en plus
avec des des règles que me dire c'est la
jungle parce que derrière il y a des
choses on parlait des algorithmes on
parlait des faussaires des fabricants de
mensonges des complotistes qui eux
viennent dans un univers totalement
débridé mettre encore plus de base ils
en profiter exactement c'est facile de
s'insérer alors c'est c'est intéressant
parce que sur ces thématique là il y a
une réflexion européenne et on va en
parler tout de suite grâce à Jonathan du
priez rebonsoir Jonathan il y a quelques
semaines le Sénat à auditionner des
représentants français de de médias en
amont d'un futur règlement europ
européenne européen pour protéger
justement la liberté d'informer vous y
étiez Christophe Deloire d'ailleurs
l'Union européenne elle veut muscler en
son arsenal juridique pour protéger la
liberté de la presse ça ça s'appelle en
anglais le média freedom Act désolé pour
l'accent mais il a été dévoilé donc à
l'automne 2022 par la Commission
européenne et il vise à garantir pour
les 27 États membres des médias libres
pluriels et dans le détail alors si on
regarde du règlement il y a des
dispositions pour renforcer
l'indépendance déstructure elle-même des
journalistes limiter les conflits
d'intérêt garantir la stabilité des
financements à louer aussi à ces médias
plutôt publics d'ailleurs européen ou
encore limiter la concentration des
acteurs que vous évoquiez un peu qui est
jugez à un niveau très risqué sur
l'ensemble du continent européen et
d'ailleurs sur ce dernier point la
concentration des acteurs et ben pour
certains certaines personnes interrogées
lors de cette table ronde et bien ça
apparaît encore une notion un peu floue
écouter cette historien
l'important c'est la toxicité éventuelle
du propriétaire ou de la concentration
c'est pas la concentration en elle-même
c'est même pas la propriété en elle-même
on peut être
vendeur d'avions de chasse et d'armement
comme le groupe d'assaut et garder le
Figaro comme il était avant et comme il
sera prêt c'est-à-dire un journal
conservateur de droite catholique machin
etc mais le journal n'a pas changé parce
que il a été racheté par Dassault donc
on l'a compris l'objectif c'est de faire
adopter un texte harmonisé au niveau
européen forcément ça va être compliqué
ouais c'est là que ça se complique hein
parce que ça promet des bras de fer
intenses entre les 27 démocraties
européennes qui ne sont pas toutes au
même niveau en matière de liberté de la
presse en creux en vérité ce règlement
ils vise au premier chef certaines
démocraties qu'on pourrait qualifier 10
libéral comme la Hongrie d'orbane ou la
Pologne de Douda sans toutefois les
nommer bien sûr ces pays qui pourtant
des démocraties je le répète se sont
illustrés ces dernières années dans leur
volonté de restreindre les libertés
publiques individuelles mettant à mal
les libertés d'informer à titre de
comparaison je reprends vraiment votre
classement Christophe de Loire la
Hongrie elle est classée 72e sur 180
pays dans le classement RSF et alors que
l'Allemagne elle est 21e pourtant tout
le monde est dans l'Union européenne
donc toutes ces personnes qui ont été
auditionnées au Sénat s'accordent à dire
que c'est utile voire urgent de
légiférer au niveau européen pour
empêcher ces dérives empêcher ces
régimes en tout cas de dérivés au
passage d'armée un peu mieux ceux qui
n'ont pas encore ces problèmes là
écoutez
il y en a plusieurs en Europe et on
n'est pas à l'abri même en France un
jour de se retrouver dans un régime il
libéral et donc il n'est pas
inintéressant en France de s'interroger
à cette possible configuration qui
puisse arriver un jour et donc de voir
comment aussi en France on pourrait se
prémunir d'un éventu de l'arrivée
éventuelle d'un régime et libéral et
comment l'Europe pourrait peut-être nous
aider en ce sens voilà et ce qui
ressortait aussi de cette table ronde
c'est en tout cas que les sénateurs
jugés que l'Union européenne allait
peut-être un peu trop loin dans son dans
ses prérogatives par rapport au
réglementations des États membres et
pour un simple exemple il y a plusieurs
dispositions de ce texte qui nous
obligerait français a changé
fondamentalement notre loi de 1881 voire
même peut-être celle de l'audiovisuel de
1986 merci Jonathan Christophe de Loire
j'ai parfois tendance à me dire ouh là
là quand les politiques se s'occupent de
vouloir légiférer sur les libertés de la
presse attention danger comment vous
réagissez à ça mais il y a deux types de
régulation et qu'on rien à voir avec
l'autre et la régulation de contenu
statué sur les exceptions légitimes à la
liberté d'expression
et il y a un champ légitime il y a aussi
des volontés parfois de certains
d'étendre ce chant ce qui est très
dangereux en revanche donner des
obligations de moyens aux acteurs donc
là de nature processus pour favoriser le
netteté de l'information pour favoriser
le pluralisme tout à l'heure vous disiez
Thomas Hugues que il y avait
du pluralisme ici à l'antenne mais c'est
aussi une obligation qui est faite par
la régulation c'est votre bonne volonté
mais c'est aussi la régulation qu'il
impose à la télévision et d'ailleurs il
y a un enjeu sur ce sujet vis-à-vis de
cnews c'est qu'on est en train de se
sortir de ce modèle et en fait
il est légitime que le Parlement
un système démocratique impose des
obligations démocratiques alors là le
chaos informationnel j'ai oublié
l'expression que tu disais le bazar le
grand bazar décrit fait qu'il faut
repenser cette régulation parce que
ce que font les plateformes ce que font
les réseaux sociaux c'est totalement
inédit dans l'histoire il faut inventer
de nouveaux principes juridiques ça
c'est un travail auquel on essaie de
s'attacher beaucoup alors il y a un
début puisqu'il y a déjà des textes
européens qui sont imparfaits mais le
digistol service Isaac et digital market
sacs de législation européenne sur les
services sur les marchés numériques mais
on voit qu'il faut aller plus loin et
par exemple il y a un très grand enjeu
et on est en train de se battre pour
pour que ce soit intégré dans la
législation européenne le règlement
européen dont on vient de parler c'est
pour la première fois et ça c'est quand
même assez inédit dans l'histoire
récente démocratie en tout cas depuis la
fin du 19e siècle il y a un avantage
dans le fonctionnement algorithmique les
biais cognitifs pour tous ceux qui
propagent les rumeurs diffusent de la
propagande des contenus corrompus etc
ils sont au centre de l'espace public
ils ont cette espèce d'avantage par le
fonctionnement les algorithmes pour
quand il s'agit de remonter ou descendre
les contenus ont toutes sortes de
critères et des centaines de critères il
y en a un qui n'existe pas c'est sur la
fiabilité de l'information c'est être
ceux qui ont est-ce que ceux qui ont
produit le contenu ont respecté des
principes de fiabilité et encore une
fois sans dire est-ce que les contenus
doivent être de droite de gauche
évidemment avec une neutralité politique
avec une neutralité idéologique
religieuse etc et là dessus il est
absolument essentiel qu'avec l'adoption
du règlement européen il y a une
obligation plateforme numérique de
remettre un indicateur de fiabilité pour
que l'espace public redevienne celui
qu'il a été depuis dans le développement
de la démocratie avec la promotion de la
fiabilité de l'information puisque vous
ouvrez
ce débat cette partie concernant les
algorithmes et donc on va dire les gens
de l'Internet pour être pour simplifier
les médias sociaux les réseaux sociaux
je vais reprendre
en détail certains éléments du baromètre
publié par nos confrères de la croix
pour cette année 2023 alors il y a
d'abord le chiffre général sur les
chiffres généraux sur la confiance des
Français médias par média regardez ça 54
% des Français déclarent faire confiance
à ce qu'ils entendent à la radio c'est
ce qui vient en premier ensuite on a les
journaux de presse écrite 52% après on
trouve la télévision 49% et ensuite 33%
internet très bien mais alors si on
regarde un peu plus loin par tranche
d'âge et qu'on s'intéresse aux plus
jeunes au 18 24 ans
la question quel média privilégiez-vous
pour être informé au quotidien c'est pas
exactement la même chose la confiance ou
qu'est-ce que je regarde ou qu'est-ce
que je lis jour de télévisé
l'information en premier 25 % réseau
sociaux ça vient en deux 16% et puis
ensuite émission d'actualité et de
divertissement intéressant c'est fait
mélanger à la télévision
plus ils sont jeunes plus la distance
enfin c'est une évidence mais il faut là
il faut peut-être la détailler
Jean-Bernard plus de la distance
vis-à-vis de ce que les médias sociaux
et internet proposent et faible c'est ça
en fait en plus c'est la double peine
parce que d'abord plus ils sont jeunes
plus ils sont de fait réceptifs à ce
qu'il y a parce qu'ils sont plus
numériques donc ils vont plus facilement
sur les réseaux sociaux donc c'est assez
simple en fait mais dans les faits puis
ils sont jeunes moins ils ont et là il y
a pas de jugement de valeur c'est la vie
c'est comme ça moins ils ont de bagages
de recul de bagages culturel de
connaissances de l'info du Monde etc
pour prendre du recul par rapport à ce
qu'ils vont lire c'est pour ça c'est une
question d'éducation c'est une question
d'éducation merci de me lancer sur le
sujet parce que c'est un peu mon cheval
la bataille je suis pas le seul
et d'ailleurs enfin je précise c'est pas
le seul public qu'il faudrait éduquer
surtout pas hélas mais c'est vrai que
c'est une question d'éducation et plus
on sait quand même aperçu d'une chose
plutôt on
essaye danser des reflexes de du recul
par rapport à l'information mais dès
l'école primaire plutôt on commence à
mettre en place des mécanismes de
questionnement d'esprit critique par
rapport à l'information et pas
simplement la formation média parce
qu'en fait c'est aussi ce qui est
terrible c'est que cette profusion
d'information et cette désinformation
touche tous les champs on s'en aperçoit
avec la science on s'en aperçoit avec
moi tous les champs plutôt on arrivera à
inculquer ça mieux on arrivera à armer
les gens ça sera pas c'est pas la
panacée ne rêvons pas non plus c'est pas
la panacée mais c'est une manière
forte d'agir dès le régime
je voudrais revenir rapidement juste sur
cette typologie qui était faite et sur
la confusion dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure entre la notion de source la
notion de canal les réseaux sociaux sont
isolés comme une source en fait sauf que
moi il m'arrive très souvent en étant
sur Twitter de regarder des extraits de
LCP je suis sur la télévision je suis
sur les réseaux sociaux les deux m'ont
général évidemment donc là il y a un
sujet qu'il faut qu'il faut évidemment
travailler en tant que tel pour être
plus rigoureux dans ce qu'on analyse
mais évidemment je vous rejoins sur
cette question de l'éducation et donc
pour pour embrayer là-dessus j'ai
participé en fait aux assises du
journalisme à la restitution de de la
mission parlementaire sur l'éducation
critique aux médias et ce qui m'a frappé
c'est qu'en fait aujourd'hui l'éducation
aux médias il y a beaucoup de choses qui
existent il y a un enjeu évidemment de
rationalisation de déploiement à
l'échelle mais je pense aussi un enjeu
de priorisation des publics pas
seulement sur des critères socio-démo en
gros l'âge mais aussi sur des notions de
système de valeurs c'est la grille de
lecture que nous travaillons et on voit
que il y a des publics qui sont beaucoup
plus défiant que d'autres que ça
correspond en fait à des visions du
monde et que c'est cela qu'il faut
cibler en priorité on se la question des
nouveaux ennemis de l'information je
voudrais juste donner la parole à un
journaliste à l'agence française qui
fait partie des de ceux qui vérifient
des fact checker ils s'appellent marin
et voilà ce qui nous dit quand il est
comment il travaille quoi tout
simplement quand il est confronté à une
fausse information et qu'il essaie de la
voilà des bunks pardon c'est un horrible
anglicisme la vérifier merci les fausses
informations et les rumeurs circulent
bien plus vite que le enfin que le temps
que ça prend pour rétablir la vérité
donc nous on essaie d'aller vite et
c'est vrai quand on arrive à faire une
vérification
solide qu'on publie rapidement il y a un
certain satisfaction parce que on se dit
que peut-être ça va ralentir un petit
peu la viralité de cette info
informations on l'a déjà dit ici une
fausse information va beaucoup plus vite
qu'une qu'une vraie sur sur internet en
général pardon de de généraliser mais je
voudrais qu'on parle des nouveaux des
nouveaux ennemis que ça doit dire quand
même dans ce débat même s'il t'enfile
trop vite sur l'intelligence
artificielle ça peut être un outil
génial on va pas être la diabolisation
ridicule mais il y a quand même un
risque en matière d'information pourquoi
l'enjeu c'est d'en faire un outil génial
et vous savez il y a la notion de
pharmacon de ces choses qui peuvent être
à la fois un remède et un poison notre
enjeu démocratique c'est d'en faire des
remèdes plutôt que des poisons
tout simplement parce que c'est un
potentiel de création de contenu
inédit
qui n'a plus rien à voir avec ce qui
était les moteurs de recherche
et que cette création aujourd'hui même
s'il y a des développements un peu
nouveau et qu'on est en train d'essayer
de travailler mais elle est pas fondée
sur le critère de véracité du tout
c'est purement probabiliste et la vérité
c'est pas probabilité et donc on peut
même si on demande de rédiger votre
portrait de quelqu'un qui soit autour de
la table tombé sur quelque chose qui n'a
rien à voir avec la vérité donc il
suffit de le faire beaucoup d'éléments
qui racontent n'importe quoi sur
quelqu'un pour qu'il se dise ah bah
tiens puisque ça
retrouver éviter cette perte de contrôle
technologique c'est compliqué mais pour
ça il y a des moyens et là-dessus moi je
veux dire le rôle du Parlement
évidemment qu'il est important alors je
voudrais donner
on s'est dit qu'on allait pas contribuer
au maximum à l'anxiété sur ces sujets
quand même le rapport Brenner qui date
de janvier 2022 rappelle de façon
générale que les contenus de
désinformation sont bien moins
nombreuses sont ultra minoritaires à la
fois dans ce qui est disponible et dans
ce qui est consommé par le consommateur
d'information voilà il faut quand même
rappeler ça pour aimer tout ce qu'elle
dit évidemment est très vrai et la
difficulté étant de faire le tri malgré
tout bien sûr on y revient
juste je complète oui ça rejoint ce que
vous disiez précédemment certes
peut-être que sur la masse ils sont
moins nombreux mais d'abord il faut il y
a un enjeu vers le trip mais surtout ils
vont toucher toujours les mêmes publics
c'est-à-dire que justement la
concentration sur les mêmes publics fait
énormément de dégâts bon la profession
de journaliste n'est pas la profession
préférée des Français et les politiques
qui participent peut-être puisque c'est
une semble favorite souvent des des
politiques Laetitia où il y a retirer
notre attention sur un tweet qui a fait
beaucoup réagir depuis hier celui de
Mathilde panot député la France
insoumise de la dixième circonscription
du Val-de-Marne oui la député à soumise
a écrit un truc hier en réaction à la
Une du journal Le Parisien je ne sais
pas si vous l'avez vu le journal titré
sur la Baya cette tenue religieuse que
de plus en plus de jeunes femmes jeunes
filles portent dans les établissements
scolaires la députée de la France
insoumise donc a écrit nous traversons
une crise sociale sans précédent une
attaque massive des libertés sous Macron
une sécheresse ultra précoce et une
guerre alimentaire ce profil mais le
Parisien fait ça une sur la tenue des
femmes musulmanes pour ce journal comme
beaucoup d'autres l'islamophobie fait
vendre surtout quand elle s'attaque aux
femmes vous nous dites ce tweet est une
honte exactement c'est une honte parce
que il fait peser une menace directe sur
les journalistes du Parisien comme l'a
dit en réaction un très rapidement le
philosophe Raphaël Enthoven panneau leur
a collé une cible sur le dos et n'est
pas le seul Raphaël Enthoven avoir réagi
dans ce sens est beaucoup ont rappelé
que l'accusation d'islamophobie tue
aujourd'hui elle tue ceux qui en sont
accusés évidemment on pense aux
attentats contre la rédaction de Charlie
Hebdo 7 janvier 2015 à cause des
caricatures du prophète Mahomet mais
évidemment c'est à dire qu'il faudrait
demander aujourd'hui aux membres de la
France insoumise qui est Charlie qui est
encore Charlie peut-être c'était il y a
8 ans Thomas et aujourd'hui nous en
sommes là des politiques désigne des
journalistes comme des cibles à des fins
clientalistes parce que bien sûr que la
France insoumise vise un électorat et
c'est l'électorat musulman en France je
ne sais je ne sais pas si le parti a eu
des consignes de communication dans ce
sens mais il n'y a pas eu uniquement
Mathilde panneau qui a eu ce type de
message d'autres voix de LSI en temps
brillé comme par exemple le député à la
fille du Nord David Guiraud qui lui
carrément d'un cran en mettant tous les
journalistes dans le même sac c'était
sur BFM je pense qu'il y a des
permanences dans notre pays depuis
quelques années quand c'est Noël il y a
toujours la chanson de Mariah Carey et
dès qu'il fait plus 25 degrés on parle
des musulmans quoi franchement moi je
suis encore l'année dernière on nous
sortit qui avait une épidémie d'abahia
moi je me suis lancé épidémie d'Aya
est-ce qu'on peut faire le constat il y
a une épidémie de Bahia ou pas je sais
pas il assume pas tout à fait ce qui
laisse entendre c'est que les médias
font mal leur travail que l'islamophobie
surtout c'est ça qui est important est
devenu une sorte de marronnier
exactement c'est très grave très grave
ce type d'accusation on connaissait
mépris de Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour les
journalistes qui a d'ailleurs
certainement contribué à son succès mais
là la France insoumise va encore plus
loin dans le populisme et récupère
instrumentalise la défiance des Français
envers les médias en l'empirant c'est
indigne napolitique Thomas dans le
climat de tension dans lequel nous
sommes plongés depuis quelques mois
brandir l'argument de l'islamophobie
pour discréditer les médias revient oui
c'est vrai à mettre une cible sur le dos
des journalistes c'est irresponsable et
objectif les journalistes punching-ball
préféré des politiques alors c'est pas
nouveau Laetitia ça fait des années voir
des décennies que ça dure est-ce que
vous diriez qu'un cran supplémentaire
est franchi Jean-Bernard Schmitt moi je
trouve qu'un cran que supplémentaire
j'ai toujours considéré alors ça c'est
très personnel c'était les principales
défaites démocratiques quand des
politiques commençaient à s'en prendre à
des journalistes mais franchement mais
c'est c'est d'une faiblesse franchement
je les ai pas entendu ces propos c'est
d'une faiblesse totale
c'est d'autant plus grave que et c'est
ça rejoint ce qu'on se disait nous
sommes dans un monde totalement
désorganisé nous sommes dans un monde
déjà
ultra violent en matière
informationnelle c'est-à-dire que
justement le politique devrait être au
rendez-vous pour consolider cette base
démocratique la réalité quand on voit ce
qui se passe dans les autres pays et
tout ça c'est que la liberté de la
presse c'est extrêmement fragile mais
c'est super fragile et donc on est dans
un monde où cette liberté est menacée
pas par chez nous le gouvernement mais
simplement parce que par tout cet
écosystème informationnel qui est
totalement déréglée on sait qu'il y a
des pays dans lesquels ça se passe
beaucoup plus violemment au contraire
les politiques devraient être les
garants en permanence de cette non
seulement liberté mais en plus de cette
je dirais qui es-tu du journalistique il
ne faut pas inquiéter il ne faut pas
stigmatiser ce type concourent à la
diffusion de l'information alors dans ce
débat on a essayé aussi de voilà de
reconnaître qu'il y a des erreurs
journalistiques de balayer devant notre
porte donc
enfin moi je peux l'esprit tranquille
dire attention quand les politiques font
ce genre de choses vous y intervenir oui
je vais évidemment j'abonde dans le sens
de ce qui vient être dit mais pour aller
un grand plus loin en faisant cela les
politiques jouent contre même en réalité
parce que ce qu'on voit du point de vue
de l'opinion c'est que la défiance
vis-à-vis des journalistes et la
défiance vis-à-vis des politiques c'est
les deux faces d'une même pièce
dans le même système quoi c'est souvent
ce qu'on entend les personnes qui disent
aussi que les politiques manipulent
l'information que ils sont amenés à voir
ou à lire voilà donc finalement c'est
c'est dangereux mais c'est aussi il joue
contre même Christophe de Loire c'est
les attaques contre la presse c'est
jamais un bon signe dans une démocratie
est-ce que vous ça fait partie des
critère qui font remonter ou baisser un
pays dans votre classement
critères économiques sociales législatif
il y a un critère politique et et ça
joue non pas que les les médias et être
exemps de toute critique
et d'ailleurs je pense que quand on fait
des erreurs on devrait plus souvent le
dire quoi parce que
absolument mais là on est dans une
espèce de logique de culture de
l'annulation on est quand même de plus
en plus dans une société où tout le
monde a envie de censurer tout le monde
ou beaucoup estiment que on est
démocrate qu'à la condition de penser
comme nous et je pense que notre rôle
c'est aussi quand même de discuter du
socle commun et il y a quelque chose qui
dépasse nos propres croyances le
journaliste d'ailleurs doit être une
forme d'ouverture alors il lui arrive de
se comporter comme une cléricature
morale de lui-même
faire de l'annulation et et ça c'est
extrêmement négatif je pense que le
journaliste doit être une posture
modeste qui prend en charge le fait que
on peut penser tout à fait autrement que
c'est pas parce que on a le sentiment de
moi je me suis toujours interrogé sur
une espèce de dualité entre les vérités
et la réalité d'ailleurs avec des
vérités factuelles on peut finalement
d'une certaine manière
occulter une partie de la réalité parce
que il y a d'autres vérités factuelles
qui peuvent être
on a eu tort de critiquer Trump sur une
chose qui est l'expression fait
alternatif non pas que Trump avait
raison quand il disait qu'il y avait un
monde fou à sa première intronisation je
suis pas du tout en train de défendre
Trump mais c'est vrai que ça existe des
fèves alternatives et c'est d'autres
aspects de la réalité il faut l'assumer
etc
je crois qu'il avait dit fait alternatif
et justement on est un peu et donc oui
on peut voir la réalité de manière
radicalement différente tout en étant
soucieux de vérité et ça faut aussi
l'assumer
merci je vois le jazz
c'est là qu'on a des professionnels
c'est quand je fais ça effectivement ça
veut dire que bah l'émission est
terminée et que c'est le moment de de
rappeler qu'à des livres et donc si vous
voulez aider reportir sans frontières
vous pouvez acheter ce livre la mer vu
par les plus grands photographes sans
photo pour la liberté de la presse et
puis Jean-Bernard Schmitt votre anti
fake news qui est une quand même une
sorte de guide voilà qui est quand on
quand on est perdu dans ce dans ce grand
bazar dont vous nous parliez et ben on
peut lire anti fake news et publié chez
First merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous dis à lundi
pour un nouveau numéro de sens public
vous pouvez également nous retrouver sur
la plateforme public sénat.fr notre
émission et toutes les autres sont en
replay et puis notez que demain dans la
matinale Oriane Mancini reçoit Alexis
Corbières député elle est fit de
Seine-Saint-Denis peut-être lui
parlera-t-elle de Mathilde panot et de
ses attaques contre la presse qui c'est
bonne soirée
[Musique]